my name is max I'm not even the main
protagonist of this movie but I am the
narrator Paul walls is far' blood and
dust and gasoline and oil and more dust
and further dust also Tom Hardy is
forced to speak unintelligibly cliche
also narration it was hard to know who
was more crazy me or everyone else if
max was still Mel Gibson the answer
would be fairly easy to figure out me
this film is fucking gorgeous by the way
most of anything we're gonna say about
this movie definitely isn't gonna be
enough to hate it max is a dick to
two-headed lizard things these cars made
no sound until they made an appearance
in the film I am the one who runs from
both the living and the dead are you any
better at running from the dead than you
appear to be at running from the living
okay sure you get the pleasure of making
a guy run behind you as you take him to
your leader but now you have to drive
all slow and I'd get tired of driving
like this after one minute tattoo
instructions also during the apocalypse
there's plenty of testing strips to
determine blood type
after patiently letting them tattoo him
for hours max finally breaks at the
mirror distant idea of being branded
also our hero just escaped after being
chained up by like four dudes in a cave
as all heroes do if you're wondering if
you're on drugs or my frames are missing
relax this is a director's choice to
intentionally remove a few frames here
and there to help you feel the same urge
intensity max is feeling of course if
you have actual anxiety issues or PTSD
this only serves to increase your
personal anxiousness parallel to
whatever the film tension it develops
but they actually anxious sorry why all
these guys bald and painted white movie
has zero interest in explaining and
while I'm tempted to remove sins for
balls eNOS I have to award a sin for
sheer wardrobe druvan character
development what is this a summer
blockbuster or a tool video it's almost
like George Miller made several anti ex
machina here things that make it look
like max will be safe turn out to not be
all that helpful after all like here a
minute ago you thought damn it he's
going to escape with the random chain
hanging down but nope I mean it's almost
like Miller's punking ex machina
we respect that wait when did these guys
get crane hook pulling hooks did they
know they need them while they were
mindlessly chasing after max this crazy
son of a bitch must rule with absolute
terror because it would take like one
day of not cleaning that wound for
infection and sweet sweet death to sit
in
the important part is cool but he
decided to stick with Joe not immortan
hellbeast or father fury sexy Joseph the
pushy or any other thousand badass
things you could change your name to if
you're a fascist dictator Joe Diaz like
this movie introduces us to the
awesomeness that is furiosa here my only
question is considering how all the
attractive women are treated in this
town basically immortan joe's personal
baby factory
how did furiosa escape that life anyway
I look like Charlize Theron but trust me
I'm Way better at driving trucks okay
first of all how is the region's water
somehow located and contained a dozen
stories up on a rock thingy doesn't this
defy all science and gravity knowledge
second of all this is the least
efficient water gifting system ever
invented I realize he's a dickhead but
he's literally wasting 90% of the water
he's releasing right now I've got a wall
boy running on empty
is this the only kind of clean kind of
normal-looking person here does being
kind of a doctor give you hair
privileges huh
sudden apocalyptic eight maids a-milking
also here are some slave women who are
being treated like literal cows just to
drive home the point that this is a
really fucked up situation
let's literally dehumanize some fat
women society's easiest targets but in
furiosa wait until she was completely
out of view before she made that turn
did they hole up in a giant stone
Citadel where a vault
already happened to be or lug one over
from what used to be known as a bank and
the first thing Joe thinks after seeing
Furioso take an unexpected turn is oh no
I bet my harem has been stolen
Oh so how did she coordinate the
smuggling of all those pregnant women
into her truck without anyone seeing
them not to mention breaking into this
safe and slipping past everyone in the
complex shoot him already I'm gonna die
historic on the fury road roll credits
whoa this society of criminal assholes
takes one of the few Universal donors
they come across and straps him to the
spiky front of a war vehicle headed into
battle because why again even if you
think his blood might come in handy on
the battlefield do you seriously want to
spill it intentionally like this isn't
this a valued commodity these flames
would definitely have already killed
this back riding asshole if only due to
wind not to mention how hot all the
metal he's touching would be
this porcupine car is useful only if
attacked by stab a bull flesh based
human thinks otherwise just throw a
gasoline water balloon at it and set the
fire I mean right
CGI crash sticks out like a sore thumb
when most of this movie is shot with
practical effects and look I've gotta
ask doesn't tying your blood bag on the
front of the car like this somehow
completely screw up your point of view
can you see why not time to the roof
you know ya gotta admire people who are
willing to die for a cause but making
the paint hover your god of the
afterlife is taking it too far
ah yes the old lose them in the
unnatural dust storm of lightning and
radiation trick hey wait
furiosa ripped off the Mutara nebula
maneuver from the Wrath of Khan this
asshole cares about a compass reading
instead of you know just following the
fugitive in front of him in this is a
sandstorm right how is the flesh of
Max's face not sandblasted off riding in
the open air back here enlightening
tells knucks where the war machine is in
the middle of this all-encompassing
Stan's storm this semi is able to drive
close enough to a SAN lightning tornado
to push this other nearby vehicle into
oblivion without somehow getting sucked
into the tornado itself everybody
survives this wicked crash including max
who flops off the car like a plaything
while the wreckage somehow misses him
completely as they bounce on the ground
meanwhile after nothing else it all
happened in the nine hours following
that heroin scene let's all take a
second to ponder the mind of a man who
developed this device also you gotta
admire how immortan joe decided my
chastity belts will have an opening but
just in case you feel they need to stick
your pecker in there I'm gonna put claws
all around it I'd rather hurt you for
your horniness rather than simply
prevent it in the first place
also since these women were all locked
up in a harem vault why was there ever a
need for such things these assholes find
them they just went through a sandstorm
where everybody who chased them either
died or got knocked unconscious what
kind of tracks did they leave that led
them here you know just in case I'm
hanging around outside my trunk with no
weapons I've got this HIDA gun thing
here in case of emergencies that's the
second time since he took possession of
this gun that he's fired three shots to
stop someone in their tracks how many
does he have left and why is he so
looking wasteful of the precious few
bullets he has does he need to fire
three times as a warning twice how the
hell did these assholes not caught up to
them already Helen they found out
furiosa altered course they were there
in like five minutes now it takes them
forever to catch up oh the legs you have
that was attached to his favorite what
are you gonna tell him max was the one
responsible for it why would you do that
and why is he in any more danger than he
was in already such an odd odd think to
say this truck with a super head start
still can't get away fast enough to keep
this asshole from catching up and
jumping aboard although I suppose it's
possible I should be sitting how quickly
this asshole woke up from his second
bout with unconsciousness inside 10
minutes he's a crazy Smeg Joey why not
go what oh yeah but don't you now leave
all the women alone up here with all
those weapons you meticulously took out
of their reach a minute ago luckily
knucks has a soft sand dune to land on
when pushed out of a speeding war
machine whatever you do you can't be
seen I'm supposed to be alone didn't you
just say I need you here you may have to
drive the wreck those sound like
contradictory statements Justin Bieber's
post-apocalyptic masturbatory fantasy
coincidental pregnancy noises now forced
us to send babies how do you like that
Philadelphia you don't need to be
criticized for booing Santa Claus
anymore lots of gunfire at this mostly
fuel carrying big rig result in a buncha
ricochets but seriously this run through
the pass is 2015 action gold and I
cannot help but remove two sins for its
edge of my seat thrills as well as its
incredible attention to detail and
continuity splendid totally did not get
out of the way of this rock in time but
pregnancy bellies offer a respite from
time and space although I will say
despite this George Miller remains true
to the anti ex machina by making her
fall off right after this but still she
should be dead and dead here - but then
she does die anyway damn man so many
things to sin so many things to make up
for it to sin - great angry and impotent
machine gun fire this girl is not
remotely surprised by the sudden enemy
on board their escape vehicle not only
that but she also sees through his
rambling and instantly decides this is a
guy she wants to marry soon guy who has
dedicated his entire life to impressing
Joe gives up totally and joins the good
guys because the power of sand boners is
super strong what the who names their
cysts let alone draw smiley faces on
them is this sudden love story a thing
is that all it takes man immortan joe
ruined this girl's future relationships
this movie makes it seem like they drive
way further than a semi should be able
to drive on one tank of gas leak cars
explode and the rest of the convoy
immediately stops instead of going
around or avoiding the semis tracks
altogether I mean you guys do realize
there are no boundaries keeping you from
going left or right right Elvis
Presley's granddaughter plays the
pronoun game and she does not get a pass
because of that Oh
so why is knucks driving the war machine
away without reintroducing himself or
same one work this high ground just
beyond that thing he means the tree
magical war machine towing tree just
happens to be within reach in the middle
of freaking nowhere already belongs to
Jimi Hendrix despite all the explosions
and bullets no one even gets hurt during
this attack tiny tree has the ability to
withstand what was it furiosa you're
sitting on 2,000 horsepower from nitro
boosted one machine sounds like a
vehicle that needs that kind of power is
probably super heavy truck that was just
struggling to drive in this on a flat
surface is suddenly climbing sand hills
with ease birds flying away to signify a
recent big gas explosion cliche totally
matte shadow guy has given a whole scene
of potential tension even though the
entire audience knows this is max
leaving it's not his blood how do you
know that want to know more about these
assholes or why the father dude has a
mask or why his followers paint
themselves white well too bad you this
movie is kicking too much ass to give
you that kind of woodsy backstory crap
and nothing of consequence happened the
next 12 hours because production based
lighting concerns oh he's getting a bug
off his luck oh please don't eat that
bug please don't eat oh god he ate the
bug Red Alert red alert d8 the god damn
bug red alert and oh yeah where the hell
did his sis based smiley faces go no
offense but that is a really lame clan
name umm why the hell does this look out
naked
is there one good reason for that I'm
not complaining I'm just trying to
figure out how that benefits the cause
whoa furiosa was her name when she lived
in the puppy dog tribe just assume she
took it on when she was kidnapped by the
cult of hideous rape monsters
Max's flashbacks don't matter much to me
or the film look I understand my furiosa
and her crew are ready to navigate 160
days of salt flats to wherever that's
supposed to go but why are the other
self-sufficient badass ladies ready to
make that same Drive I think has been
waiting for furiosa to show up so they
can say finally female Easy Rider across
the salt flats litres of water come from
he pumps it up amazing he was able to
find this fountain of water surrounded
by a huge ass rock fortress and like
every angry parent ever threatened they
are turning this car around when all
that way to pick up some seeds basically
[Music]
what the hell are these assholes doing
do they assume Furioso will be coming
back through here if they have no idea
where they went then why haven't they
given up this guy finally gets a break
and it's like the most uncomfortable
looking break since Lawrence Taylor
sacked Joe Theismann I totally agree
that their decision to go back to the
Citadel is something they needed to do
but good they've tried to be a little
bit more discreet when they drove back
the other way maybe trying to avoid
being seen maybe even I don't know take
a circle around in fact how the hell did
they know when Wharton Joe didn't give
up and decide to go back to the Citadel
they simply assumed he'd still be
hanging out waiting for no reason ruby
has a siphoning gas to blow it directly
into your engine off these pogos essence
are really cool why didn't they have
these things earlier when they attack
the war rig sure use that go down into
the driver's seat and choke the person
method instead of using any kind of
weapon that might kill her and then this
right now
and whatever bomb this is took wait too
long to go on Jesus now these guys can
officially get up close to the heroes
their weapons of choice are now
cumbersome slow and beatable also can
you not close this sunroof why do you
keep it open during an attack wait are
you sure is she strong enough to catch a
falling Tom Hardy with one hand while
driving this massive war machine why
didn't kick this dude out or kill him in
the first place did he think he just sit
here and do nothing the whole time I
actually incorporated the flame-throwing
guitar guy into the action too since
were moved uh no but I guess you need
your bad guy turned good guy to have a
dramatic death so why not superhuman
strength for this scene only ah yes
here's the ex machina the movie's been
waiting for thank God max is a universal
donor and he knows how to withdraw and
give blood to a dying person after all
from what we know about max from the
first few movies that guy is virtually a
doctor holy Sh these people are ripping
Joe's body to shreds you know what
they're probably gonna do eat it yep she
managed to spot him in that crowd well
this movie blew our balls off it's
pretty where I movie this good gets made
especially by a major studio
good job guys
oh what a lovely died
[Music]
this is such a bad little tree you're
not even gonna sweat that far
I hope they are watching their see
they'll see and they don't know and
they'll say why she wouldn't even have
you that way you'll be malfunctioning
within a day you near-sighted scrap pile
if I pull that off will you die it would
be extremely painful you're a big guy
for you
[Music]